over a week in March there was chaos on
Turkey's border with Greece we watched
as migrants from the Middle East and
well beyond pushed at the European
Union's frontier they were encouraged
there by turkeys government told the
border would be open each had their own
motivation their own story the most
escaping war or poverty or both this is
the story of one of them shot and killed
here a faceless migrant whose death was
dismissed as fake news and whose life
was not a concern two months on we have
pieced together what we can a paper
trail conversations with family and
friends and a face with a name Mohammad
Gulzar this is the effect his death had
Sabich Ana's Muhammad's wife
we found her outside the hospital on the
day he was shot she had just identified
his body we now know that they were only
just married an hour earlier he had been
at the border fence with her shots were
fired seven people were hit the moments
were captured on multiple cameras filmed
by other migrants the footage has now
been collated by investigative teams
from independent fact-checking and open
source researchers at three
organizations Belen Kat forensic
architecture and light house reports and
with contributions from Sky News
specific events such as bursts of
gunfire acted as temporal indicators the
conclusion through audio-visual and
mapping analysis is that live rounds
were fired and that they came from the
direction of the Greek side
the Greek government in a statement to
us maintains their line from that day
that any suggestion they are responsible
is fake news a gross and deliberate
misinformation campaign generated by
Turkey Mohamed Gulzar we now know has a
son from a previous marriage happy to
talk to us but not comfortable showing
his identity he is suing the Greek state
for manslaughter and his lawyer has
advised him to remain anonymous our chat
and papers sent to us from his family
back in Pakistan reveals surprises
because it turns out Mohammed Gulzar had
actually lived in Greece for many years
our documents show that he was known to
the migration authorities he had a
long-standing application in for
residency his footprint there stretches
back to 2008 and his son lives and works
there now he had a job building and
maintaining home heaters he was friends
have said hard-working the money went
back to family in Pakistan which is his
son says why he left Greece at the
beginning of this year but on that same
trip he got married - it's been harder
to get clear answers here was this a
marriage of equal and genuine intentions
[Music]
this video was filmed by her
friend at the border they were all there
because they'd been told it was open the
clothes Mohammad Gulzar is wearing match
those worn when he was shot they all say
he approached the border fence to talk
to the Greek police he could speak Greek
and he wanted them to stop firing
teargas moments later he was shot the
Sun will soon submit legal documents to
the Greek courts they will contain
evidence from the investigation our
reports and these documents together
they tell the story of a heating
engineer from Pakistan whose life seemed
to be a journey to something better and
whose death no one will take
responsibility for mark stone Sky News